hi welcome to app inventor's hour of
code
we're here at the mit center for mobile
learning i'm shay
and i'm emily today we're going to show
you how to build your first android app
and it's only going to take three
minutes i can't even make a sandwich in
three minutes
that's the power of app inventor today's
app is called talk to me because well
it talks to you it's quite simple you
press a button and the phone speaks a
phrase out loud
welcome to app inventor can you make it
say anything
pretty much i could have fun with this
one
okay let's get started this is only
going to take about three minutes
to get started building an app click the
create button
from the app inventor homepage
appinventor.mit.edu
you'll need a google account to log in
this can be a gmail account
or a school account if your school uses
google apps for education
you can dismiss this splash screen for
now when you go into app inventor for
the first time
you won't have any projects so click new
project
in the upper left our first app is
called talk to me
app inventor project names can have
spaces so type in talk to me
with no spaces now you're in the design
window
where you can set up the components and
the layout of your app
our app needs a button component so
click on button
and then drag it over to the viewer and
then drop it
one of the neatest things about app
inventor is that you can see your app on
your phone
while you're building it let's get your
phone connected so that you can see the
app take shape
and test it out as you go now if you
don't have an android phone or tablet
you can still do this tutorial but
you'll need to pause this video
and go read the instructions for
starting an android emulator on your
computer
you can find out how to do that and also
get lots of other helpful information
by clicking on guide
now to get your android phone connected
to app inventor
go up to the connect menu and choose ai
companion
you'll need to have the app inventor
companion app on your phone
or tablet it's very easy to do this
just click on need help finding the
companion app
this takes you to the google play store
to download the app
the easiest thing to do is to open a qr
code reader on your phone
and scan the qr code you could also go
to the play store
and search for mit ai2 companion
okay so once you've gotten the mit ai2
companion app installed
you'll need to start it up on your phone
if you've closed the connection window
in app inventor
click once again on the connect menu and
choose
ai companion the connection window that
pops up shows you a six
character code and a qr code on the
companion app on your phone
click the button scan qr code
if you don't have a camera on your phone
you can just type in the six character
code
and then click connect with code great
now your phone is connected in real time
to app inventor
you should see the button that we've
already added to the app from now on
all of the changes you make to your app
will show up on the phone right away
seems like magic right well if you
disconnected from app inventor
you would no longer see the app on the
phone to get the app to stay on your
phone
or to pass it along to a friend's phone
you'll have to package it up
but we'll talk about how to do that
later
notice that the button we've added says
text for button 1
on it let's change that over here on the
right is the properties pane
this is where you can set the properties
for all of the components in your app
to change the text that shows up on the
button click on text
and type in talk to me
notice on your connected phone that the
button's text changes there
cool right great
so we only need one more component for
this app before we go into the blocks to
start programming
go to media and drag out a text to
speech component
click on it drag it over to the view and
drop it
you'll notice that it drops down to the
bottom under non-visible components
that's all for components now that we've
set the components for our app
we need to specify what the components
should do for that we click on blocks
and now you're in the blocks editor the
blocks editor
is where you click blocks together to
set the behavior of your app
we want our app to respond to a button
click so go to button one
and see all of the blocks that go with a
button choose button one dot click
and drop it in the work area now we have
to put in the blocks to tell the app
what to do when the button is clicked
go to the text to speech component click
on it
and see all of the blocks that go with
text to speech choose
call text to speech dot speak and drag
it over
to the when button1 dot click block
it will fit right inside and you will
hear a click when the blocks connect
i love that sound now we have one more
thing to add before testing the app out
notice that we have a blank socket here
we have to tell the speak block what to
say
to do that go to the text drawer under
built-in blocks
take a blank text block and bring that
over
click it right into the text to speech
dot speak block
another satisfying click now click on
that empty text block
and type congratulations you've made
your first app
okay you can test the app now go to your
phone and click the button
congratulations you've made your first
app if you had any trouble with this
tutorial you can view the written
version on our website
that's it uh yeah okay see you later
wait get back here well i thought the
app would be a little cooler i can talk
to myself
patience young one now that we know how
to use app inventor
possibilities are endless can we make it
respond to shaking
or let the user input their own text
absolutely
in fact in our next video that's just
what we're going to do we'll make it so
that when someone shakes the phone
it talks and also so the user can put in
their own text
awesome i can't wait
you